mmm delicious beverage oh hello and
welcome to the point did you know the
show is going to be on every two weeks
now how you did at the end of last year
a brand new gaming event was added to an
already stuffed calendar the PlayStation
experience in December capped off here
that's all gamers and media tent shows
such as pax pax east pax australia GDC
gamescom tokyo game show and of course
the electronic triple so we're not even
into the second month of 2015 and the
first expo of the year has already come
and gone pacsafe landed in san antonio
texas and before we arrived there was
already concerned that the event was
going to be sparse press and publishers
were pulling out we had offers of extra
exhibitor badges being available and it
seemed nobody was announcing any games
so the question needs to be asked and we
finally reached peak expo was the packs
down south just one tax too many the
point season 3 episode 5 is Excel one
packs too many
the first gaming convention of 2050s all
gamers press publishers on developers
descend on San Antonio a city famous for
the Alamo weird hats and the world's
worst knockoff tomb raider roller
coaster and as we all gathered in that
charming Texan town early on it felt a
lot different to pax prime in PAX East
41 the streets were quieter reminder
that the event hadn't sold out yet
scalpers were selling day one tickets at
cost price and then when we got into the
hall itself it was clear that this was a
much more modest tax there was the usual
table top area with plenty of free space
the indie mega booth took up almost half
of the video game area mid tier
publishers filling at the rest but most
of the familiar big names were nowhere
to be seen Sony Microsoft Nintendo
Activision EA rockstar Ubisoft's just to
name a few we in the price we go to
these events looking for news
announcements hands-on with new games
and to see the latest fruits blossoming
from the indie scene and save for that
last one pack Seth really didn't have
much to offer us while PAX Prime has
become the greatest consumer game show
in North America and pax east a close
second pack says felt more like your
local comic con an event that never
really stretched past it zip code an
event passed by largely unnoticed by the
wider gaming world it may seem like a
distant memory now but there was a time
not so long ago that an entire month of
video game news reviews and features
were collected and printed into a
magazine where playground rumors
couldn't be confirmed or denied until
the first week of the month when games
master pc gamer or egm hit store shelves
gamers would have to wait like world war
widows for the latest news from the
trenches I remember first visiting
gamespot back in 2003 and being
completely flabbergasted by the idea
that you could fill an entire website
solely with news about games the world
of games which had previously only
concerned whatever those monthly updates
would allow suddenly stretched outside
of my house past my playground and over
the horizon different consoles new
genres entire other cultures and
traditions of play
the world of gaming was a vast global
story and suddenly it was at our
fingertips better yet we were encouraged
to contribute we graduated from sending
in letters to magazine QA pages to
commenting on articles and on some sites
even writing our own as the internet
grew faster looking for screenshots
became a lost of the past suddenly we
could watch video play with strangers on
the other side of the world and as we
grew a confidence we began to upload our
own videos what press conference is live
and eventually learn to broadcast
ourselves and this whole time we were
encouraged to PR firms loved buzz the
media enjoyed the traffic and publishers
wanted pre-orders and so began the
tedious dance when you find ourselves
locked in where PR is so pervasive in
almost everything to do with games that
it's often hard to shake the idea that
our engagement is little more than fuel
powering some ever-growing hype machine
in recent years I've seen so many games
conventions turn into PR festivals
gamescom used to be this quaint little
European gaming get together now it has
announcements news and shed loads of
media PAX Prime and packs Easter
following suit so where III used to be
the hype show now every conference on
the calendar is another float in the
annual video game hype parade and as an
attendee sometimes it feels like you've
just bought a ticket to a big commercial
but packs a felt more like my playground
or instead of the focus being around
announcements or news or triple-a
blockbusters we were encouraged to
simply explore where there was Wonder
and discussions around games happened
between people with faces with opinions
that didn't fit neatly into tired
established data sets pacsafe felt like
it was occurring almost unknown to the
rest of the gaming world where fans of
games came from far and wide to meet to
talk and to play big enough to fill you
would wonder but intimate enough to make
you feel like it was yours in the past
few years pax has become such a staple
of the video game calendar that it's
hard to forget but it used to be just a
big get-together for fans to celebrate
gaming and while pack said was a little
on the small side it felt closer to
attending those gaming console
PR and media outlets might think that
pack Seth was a fader because really for
them it probably was but for all the
folks who traveled hours across nearby
states to get there for all the local
Texans we got to play games and cosplay
and hang out with people who enjoyed the
same hobby maybe for the first time ever
for them it was a triumphant success so
here's to an even bigger pack Seth next
year